- [Instructor] In a previous video,
we've introduced ourselves
to the idea of an orbital,
that electrons don't just orbit a nucleus
the way that a planet might orbit a star,
but really, in order to describe
where an electron is at
any given point in time,
we're really thinking about probabilities,
where it's more likely to be found
and less likely to be found.
And an orbital is a description of that,
where is it more or
less likely to be found.
And this diagram shows
us the types of orbitals
which can be found in
the various subshells
which are found in the various shells.
So you have the s subshell,
the p subshell that has three
different orbitals in it,
you have the d subshell
that has one, two, three,
four, five different orbitals in it.
And then you have the f subshells.
Now each orbital can fit two electrons.
So if you're thinking about the subshell,
the s subshell could fit two electrons,
the p subshell can fit six electrons,
the d subshell can fit 10 electrons,
and the f subshell can fit 14 electrons,
two per orbital.
Now the goal of this video is to think
about electron configurations
for particular atoms.
And to help us with that, we will look
at a periodic table of elements.
And so first, let's just think
about the electron configuration
of the simplest element.
If we're talking about
a neutral hydrogen atom,
a neutral hydrogen atom, it
has an atomic number of one
which tells us it has one proton,
and if it's neutral, that
means it has one electron.
Now where would that one electron be?
Well it would be in
the lowest energy level
or the first shell, and that first shell
has only one subshell in it.
It only has one type of orbital.
It only has an s subshell,
and so that one electron
in that neutral hydrogen
atom would go over there.
So we would say its
electron configuration 1s1,
in the first shell which is made only
of an s subshell, it has one electron.
Now what happens if we go to helium?
Well, a neutral helium atom
is going to have two electrons.
So instead of just having one
electron in that first shell,
we can fit up to two there.
So its electron
configuration would be 1s2.
Now what do you think is going to happen
when we go to lithium?
Well lithium, a neutral lithium
will have three electrons in it,
so the first two could go
to the first energy level,
the first shell, so the
first two will go 1s2,
and then the third electron is going
to go into the second shell,
and the subshell that
it's going to fill first
is the s subshell.
So then it'll go to the second shell
and start filling up the s subshell.
So notice, two electrons
in the first shell
and one electron in the second shell.
Now what about beryllium?
Well, that's gonna look a lot like lithium
but now it has four electrons.
So two of them are going to
go into the first shell, 1s2,
and then the next two are
going to fill up the s subshell
in the second shell.
I know it's a bit of a mouthful, 2s2.
Notice, we have four total electrons
which would be the case in
a neutral beryllium atom.
But what about boron?
Boron gets interesting.
A neutral boron would have five electrons.
So the first two we're going
to fill the first shell, 1s2,
now the second two are then going to go
to the second shell and
fill up the s subshell 2s2,
and then we're going to start
filling up the p subshell.
So let's see, we have one
more electron so we go 2p1.
So we're going to have one electron
in one of these p orbitals.
And then what happens
when we go to carbon?
Well it's going to look a lot like boron
but now we have one more
electron to deal with
if we have a neutral carbon atom,
it's going to have six electrons.
So then an extra electron is once again
going to fall into the p subshell
in the second shell because
that can fit six electrons.
So we're going to fill the
first shell with two electrons
then the 2s subshell with two electrons,
and then we have two more electrons
for the 2p subshell.
Now you can imagine as we get
to larger and larger atoms
with more and more electrons,
this can get quite complex.
So one notation folks often use
is noble gas configuration
where instead of saying,
okay, this is carbon,
they could say that, hey look,
carbon is going to have
the electron configuration
of helium, remember, the noble gasses
are these Group 8
elements right over here,
so it's going to have the
electron configuration of helium
which tells us this right over here,
and then from that, we're
going to also have 2s2,
2s2, and then 2p2.
You could just take helium's
electron configuration
right over here and put it right over here
and you would get exactly
what we wrote before.